欢迎收听古爱 微信木工
本期节目由菲利普电弧刀赞助
我是菲利普电弧刀用户
由于胡子多长得快又浓
需要出门的时候每天都得刮
电弧刀好不好用
差异很明显
一旦用到好的就很难回去
选择菲利普很大的原因
是因为旋转式三刀头
能够一次把不同方向生长的胡须给刮干净
不用来回刮
减少反复摩擦
整体贴压度很好
像下巴下额这些难处理的地方
也能够快速的刮干净
如果说你每天都刮
可以升级菲利普旗舰9系XP9404
它的微提切悬护科技会先提起胡须在深入切除
最有感的是一般电弧刀可能下午就冒出胡渣
这一台可以干净到晚上
还有亲肤舒适涂层能够降低50%的摩擦力
搭配三大AI会依照胡须密度刮胡动作和力道
自动调整刮得干净又舒服
如果常出差旅行或跑业务
可以选新上市的携带型S716
机身比iPhone还轻却搭载旗舰9系
同款刀头和全新升级的BLDC马达
刮户还有柔替强劲两种模式
最长80天免充电也支援无线充电
放进包包里随时都可以保持好状态
8月26号到29号
古埃限定优惠买旗舰9系
送菲利普智能音波牙刷和高速护法吹风机
买系带型S716
送安之轩限量磁吸票卡和无线充电盘
全款在想满万送千
想升级这次千万别错过
那我需要朋友可以在我们资讯上这边找到更多的说明连结
好這個禮拜跟家人跑來北海道旅遊
然後在出發之前
他有一個林口當地的地方爸爸跟我講說
千萬不要去北海道
我說為什麼不要去北海道
他說遇到熊
然後我以為說他講的熊
就是你可能在一些報導會看到
就北海道最近有一些熊海嘛
結果不是他講說
因為他上次來北海道就是7月
然後股票他媽的底要爛掉
每天都在底
底到他快要死噴出來
然後我想說好吧
那我就來破除這個迷信
結果沒想到到北海道中
這個體驗也不是非常好
但至少比7月好多
它就是一個震盪而已
沒有什麼方向性
但至少其實就是停留在差不多的一個位置
特別是像昨天跟今天就出現一些反彈
所以我覺得還OK
就是在股票體驗上還OK
但是在旅遊的體驗上
算是也長了一些見聞了
因為我們平常之前都是跑去東京
東京可能一年會去好幾次之類的
你以為說你去東京會了解什麼日本的文化
當地的風土民情
沒有我覺得東京相較之下
是一個非常世俗化的地方
也就是你去裡面住的各種飯店
因為東京的那幾個什麼五星飯店基本上蠻多都已經跑透了所以大多數就是跟你在世界各地會住到飯店的體驗是差不多的這一次來到北海道我就請A君安排一下
反正就是當地找個不錯的東西
我想說基本上預算是沒有什麼問題
就盡量是網上開讓大家舒服就好
所以他不管是在訂山西 小樽還是雜黃
直接就是往最貴的方向去訂就好
那你想說這個最貴的
可能就是跟過往的體驗是差不多
反正就是一個
你想像中飯店該有的樣子
可是到這邊真的是不太一樣
他真的是有一種
你進入了日本文化的感覺
一則一喜 一則一憂
一喜的部分就是
你真的感受到日本人的那種一絲不苟的樣貌
憂的部分真的也是蠻辛苦的
就在說像我們前面住了兩間飯店
他們都會有一些神奇的規則跟規矩
就在說你可能今天就是有一個人不吃
以前你如果不吃會怎麼樣
他说OK没有问题
反正你不吃就不吃
他也是会跟你算钱
这都是没有问题的
可是如果你今天这个人不吃
他就会开始问你说
那你要不要吃其他东西
你真的不要吗
那你要改掉的话
那请问一下你明天早餐
是不是这个人也不吃什么的
他就会给你带20个问题出来
然后再来就是拿行李回去的时候
也会开始跟你问一个问题
请问这件事几男几女
他其实在行前就已经一直记心
我想说你有这么多东西好问吗
就狂问你
每一间住几个男生几个女生
小朋友是在哪一间
我想說這個其實我們自己可以處理
而且我們回答的方式
就是跟他說就是chill
就是沒有關係
我們自己會安排
不行
他就是要打破砂鍋問到底
你可以說服務到家
可是某程度上
也是給你一種無形的壓力
除了這種東西狂問之外
再來就是早餐時間到
像其中一間飯店是
他要帶你上餐廳
其實可以理解
因為每個房間
都會有自己的一個包廂
就是餐廳是某一個區域
然後這個區域
每個人都是有自己的一個
小包廂
然後進去要脫鞋子之類的
所以他帶你去是ok的
但你的想像就是你可能到現場
然後接著他就把你帶到你的包廂
不是 他要求說你要在房間等他
然後接著他會來敲門
敲門之後你就要跟他去
可是問題是你是來放假的
你不是來7點半8點要起床的
可是他老兄就是8點就到你門口這樣
咕咕咕
然後敲死上最大聲那種
當然開門之後他一定是露出滿滿的微笑
啊早安啊要帶你去餐廳
就說好ok那我們稍微準備一下再過去
然後接著幾分鐘後再敲門
原來這個老兄在外面等你
他就說那你好的時候再跟我說但他就提醒你說我在外面等第二天就跟他講說沒關係你可以不用等我了所以他一樣先來敲門然後接著看到我兒子因為早上還要跟我泡澡一早把我挖起來泡泡完看到我兒子穿一條內褲就跑去開門
他說那沒有關係
那我們就在餐廳那邊等你
他說好那終於我們待會再自己過去就好
然後接著我開門出去
他沒有在外面
不知道為什麼突然那種鬆一口氣的感覺
覺得好像隨時被監視
然後接著稍微往旁邊走靠北
然後廊道的底端看到一個老兄
兩隻手交叉在老二前面
跟你媽行一個大禮
然後接著他就要帶你上餐廳
所以真的會有那種倒吸一口氣的感覺
想說這到底是什麼樣的變態的地方
然後再來就是你出門的時候
一開始鑰匙我們自己帶著
後來跟我們講說鑰匙不能自己帶著
請你把門鎖上之後
然後把鑰匙給我們
然後老婆就直接拿鑰匙給他說
那個門沒有鎖沒有關係
他說 Please lock the door
我說OK啦沒有關係
我們裡面沒有什麼
Please lock the door
OK OK
Sumimase
然後趕快回去lock the door
想說到底在幹嘛
然後你要回房間的時候
不是說回房間
就是你從外面開車
你們才在飯店的門口
他們一定是盯著監視器
他們就看到說你的車來了
你知道那不是什麼園區
那個就是馬路隔壁而已
所以他一定是隨時都在看著
你就知道他在看你就對了
你車子一停下來
他們就已經出來了拿鑰匙給你
有些人一定會覺得說
這個是很棒的服務什麼
可是我覺得蠻好 creepy到爆炸
但除了這些很奇怪的
日式在地的服務之外
因為他不是只有一間飯店這樣
就是蠻我們住的幾家飯店這樣
所以就讓我覺得真的是蠻恐怖的
不過
房內的各種設施或是吃的東西
跟景觀都是無從挑剔
極好
日本人真的是把事情都處理得非常好
像有一間飯店是直接就看到那個定山溪
它的景觀是很漂亮的
另外一間飯店
它外面是類似被愛道的森林
可是這兩家飯店都有一個特色
就是它沒有刻意的
像有些飯店會
它知道門口是你的景
所以要講它就造景
它可能弄了一個草皮或什麼
反正你看就是整理得非常乾淨
它看起來像是原始的樣子
原始的森林或是原始的溪谷
但同時你知道它有去做一些點綴
這個地方不應該有那個花
它這個地方有種某一種花
然後這個樹的樣子太漂亮
它不像是原本長在那邊的樹
可是它盡可能讓它看起來是原始的風茫
這我覺得蠻特別的
再來就是溫泉有一些神奇的力量
雖然查了一下好像是蠻一般的
碳栓什麼溫泉之類的
可是泡完可能是因為溫度開得夠高吧
覺得真的有非常放鬆的感覺也非常希望遇到河童因為在電三星下邊後來才知道他們當地的特產就是說當地的都市傳說就是曾經有一個什麼河童鴻的地方還是怎麼樣
反正就有河童會把人家抓下去
反正有些是把它寫成鬼故事
然後有些寫成是一種家話之類的
蠻希望遇到河童可是沒有遇到
就像我之前也很希望可以遇到雪女
然後想說這終於到比較冷的地方
有沒有機會可以遇到雪女
後來才知道說
原來雪女好像不是在北海道這邊
好像是在那個什麼
就是有種迷那個地方
不是在這裡比較可惜
但每次看到這種日本的一些
偏向他們傳說類型的東西
都很生利其盡
就是很希望真的可以遇到他
那也可能是因為日本的一些動漫
或者黃游把這個畫面做得太美好之類的
所以遇到他會有一些好事
可是同時你當然知道說
這一定是非常恐怖的
如果你真的遇到應該會嚇死
而且應該滿高的機率是遇到熊
而不是遇到這些有的沒有的東西
總之整個行程是覺得還滿不錯
多虧A君的安排
我們實在是走到爆炸
包含說可能去看了一些什麼
巧克力工廠
然後在小樽的街道上面
幾乎每個店都進去走了
也去排了一下人家那種
排隊名店
去吃什麼舒服雷之類的
這種就是以前我跟我老婆
或是說帶我們孩子
我們也不會去做的事情
但就是跟著A君他們這種年輕人
雖然他才小小兩歲
但可能這就是一般
30到32歲的人該有的樣子
但是我沒有辦法
我就是過著一個比較老人的生活
我已經很久沒有這樣子做了
跟著大家這樣走來走去
雖然超累
可是躺在沙發的時候
還是跟老婆講說
我們其實久久應該要去做這樣子的事情
提醒一下我們自己也是年輕人
不要說媽指定都在過老人家的生活
在這邊吃到的東西也都非常的好吃
就套一句我們的師父
在中國這邊他們的司機
是把他稱為師父
因為是中國籍的
他移民到
也不是說移民
就目前是定居在悲哀道這邊
之前在SARS的時候
就全家就搬過來這裡
他就提到說日本人他們有一個非常好的特點
就是他們絕對是不騙人的
所以在日本吃東西要踩到雷的機率是很低
當然講絕對不騙人一定是沒有到很準確
絕大多數是不會騙人
這個我自己非常認同
就在日本你可以隨便進入一家店
你被雷的機率都是很低的
就是該有的樣子怎麼樣就是這樣
然後不會黑你不會噓你之類的
所以雖然我們其他幫我安排一些餐廳
都會請他說去找一些那種
可能像是有包廂
或是盡量不會影響到別人
所以有一餐他就帶我們去吃一個
在小樽那邊的海鮮餐廳
我想說沒進去就只有我們
然後它的水缸裡面
就只有一隻帝王蟹
就感覺是全部都在等我們
想說會不會被人家宰了之後
但都沒有都是非常好
食物的品質也很高
所以算是過得還蠻開心的
也希望在台灣
目前正在遭遇這些風災雨災的朋友
可以順利度過這次的難關
我是希望我回家的時候
希望林口這邊不要被吹到爆掉
因為看有個颱風會直接撞頭
會直接撞到北部
希望我們北部也不要爆炸
希望大家可以
因為南部這邊看起來是
下雨下的蠻大的
希望大家的生命跟財產
都可以非常妥善的保存好
希望大家可以順利度過這次的挑戰
總之在這次的旅行之後就會回到台灣
準備開始孩子的大班
其實心中想起來真的蠻感傷的
所以這一次
像過往
據說是有這種蠻多外援在現場
我就是會躲到後面去
在這個車子我一定是躲到最後面去
然後去看我的股票
但這次因為知道說孩子很快就要大班
你已經沒有在有幾個暑假可以陪他
後面他可能就要跟他朋友玩之類的
所以我都盡可能的跟我大兒子坐在一起
然後差不多到今天是第四天
我已經瀕臨崩潰
雖然前面就有情懷
覺得說要多花時間陪孩子
明天開始我還是沒有辦法
我應該會往後面坐
但總之我在這邊也再次的提醒自己
因為孩子的成長只有一次
所以雖然問題很多
有的沒有的事情
盡可能的陪他聊天
希望自己可以做得更好
大概這樣
好 接下來跟大家聊一下
在過去一陣子
AI是怎麼樣的去影響自己的生活跟工作
特別是以工作這一塊來跟大家聊一下
因為在過去的好幾集的QA
你都會看到有些聽眾會問說
你平常是怎麼樣去準備一些資料
是怎麼樣研究標的
怎麼樣估值
怎麼樣去做每天的閱讀什麼的
其實這些東西
都跟AI有蠻大的一個關聯性
所以在這邊就稍微的跟大家講一下自己的看法
同時我覺得也是AI出來了
差不多兩三年左右的一個間短的回顧
因為有蠻多東西
確實是跟自己想像的不太一樣
像以前回去很期待說一些自動化產生
但最終發現自動化是沒有辦法產生的
因為自己的判斷還是很有價值的
雖然講這個可能某個程度上是往自己的臉上貼金
但是我相信任何在前緣打拼的人
所謂前緣打拼就是你的工作
直接影響到你的收益的多跟寡的人
應該都可以非常明確的感受到這件事情
一開始你可能會想像說自己會被AI取代
但最後發現說其實自己是不太會被AI取代
然後再來就是也會想像說
如果自己可以把AI用到很好的話是不是可以把你的競爭對手全部都幹掉但發現說大家都會用AI可能少部分不會用的他本來就會是時代的眼淚現在還會多一些新的競爭者
他本來不是這個領域的
大家可以撈過界用AI來跟你競爭
所以包含說像一些有在做量化交易的朋友
應該感覺非常的明顯
就是本來想像說AI可以快速的
幫你去做大量的回測跟找資料跟對答案之類的
所以理論上你應該會打出比較好的績效
但這個世界是建立在
據說今天就是阿摩迪達利歐
他自己有一個非常強大的AI模型
然後這個傢伙他把AI模型用在他的工作上面
然後把他虐到爆掉
那就有可能會發生
可能在市場上的一個獲利
大量的往他傾斜的一個狀況
可是問題就是大家都有這份工具的前提之下
再搭配說像我們自己的工作來講
他不完全是在處理一些分析
他还有一些信息差的问题
谁获得资讯早跟慢
然后再来还有一些情绪上的东西
跟突发的事件
就像说川普可能又做什么事情
最近的可能在民主党这边
Bernie跟AOC
他们想要去Bager资料中心
有太多的变数
都会产生一些出乎意料的变化
所以世界不是静态的
我相信如果是一个静态的世界的话
就像是刚才前面所提到的
如果说今天只有NEO模型
或是它是一個靜態的世界
AI它確實就是有可能會讓資源的分配
產生一些傾斜
但問題是世界是非常動態的
所以只能夠說
我們可能獲得了一種莫名的滿足感
你覺得說你過去
需要花兩個小時做的事情
你現在花幾分鐘都可以做完
你覺得你省下很多的時間
但每個人都摸著自己左邊的軟蛋
去思考一下
你真的有省下比較多的時間嗎
你確實是在某些議題上
你省下的時間
但其實你在工作上面
我相信絕大多數有這樣用AI的人
你發現你的工時實際上是變長的
你並沒有因為說有了AI之後
你發現說我現在打高爾夫球的時間變長了
沒有
反而是一些受聘於人的有可能
我覺得說你本來是要去處理報表的人
你發現有AI之後
你下去可以跟老闆水時間
你本來需要花兩個小時的東西
現在你可能只要花5分鐘
那剩下的一個小時又有55分鐘
就可以跑去幹嘛
可是老闆也不是白癡
老闆也知道說這東西生成報表
或是一些總結非常簡單
所以第一個被開掉的人
可能就是這些人
或是老闆第一個就跑來review你之類的
所以以一個自顧者的角度來講或是以一個公司經營者的角度來講我相信大家都有一樣的感受就是AI可能幫你在某些的事項上省下的時間
但整體在工作你花的時間是變多的
甚至有蠻多的時間是要拿來了解
就是最新的AI工具是怎麼樣
但好在下AI工具它算是越來越自動化
所以你可以直接請這些AI工具介紹說
它可以做什麼事情
它幫你省下了蠻多的時間
但整體來說就是在你工作的投入上
是花了更多的時間
你可以去狩獵更多的東西
你可以去了解更多的事情
你可以去發掘更多世界的真相
但是有沒有辦法
產出一個對應的報酬
這件事情上
其實它會是打一個蠻大的問號
就像是可能在初期
就是AI的前一年多
那時候非常流行Vibe coding
當然現在還是很多人在Vibe coding
也看到蠻多有趣的產品
跑到市場上
但是你說有誰因為這樣子大發財
我們講有誰是說
你要可以講出很多人
你不要說每個人都是舉特定幾個例子
那就跟幣圈去舉說特定的幾個人發財
那差不多的一個道理
所以你會注意到其實本質上
工作都還是繼續 生活都還是繼續
感覺AI它幫你加強了一些東西
可是它卻沒有讓你換來時間上的自由
你可能每個人他是花更多時間在工作的
所以它現在看起來跟電腦當時的誕生
雖然電腦在我有生之年就已經是在那邊了
我無法去感受到在電腦之前跟電腦之後的差距
但是我現在去稍微的把自己放入在那樣的時代去做想像的話
我覺得是差不多的一個東西
你知道有一個超級強的機器可以幫你非常有效率的去做一些事情
可是它並沒有讓你的工作時數下降
甚至讓美元的工時變長
它對社會產生一些變化
但是工作都還是繼續
所以大家想像的Universal Basic Income
搞不好以為拉到更後面的時間才會出現之類的
所以今天如果是回到我自己的工作的話
其實我現在一整天跟AI對話的時間是很長
甚至是我情願跟AI對話是優於去跟
我們這樣講自己的同意好像在吐槽人家
但你確實就是你跟自己股票圈的朋友
以前你會想要每個群組有時候可以去拋個東西
拋轉移去聊一下什麼的
下次你會發現絕大多數的東西
基本上你就是跟AI聊就好了
那當然如果你今天是一個剛加入市場的人
你比較難去做到這件事情
因為你去跟AI聊的東西
他就是從公開資訊去撈
公開資訊的東西
一般來講在市場裡面較難為你帶來一些立即性的收穫大趨勢是OK啦就是說你說報紙可不可以拿來看投資絕對是可以的因為報紙在好幾年前就跟人講說AI可以
所以如果你相信報紙你去投AI
你過去幾年都賺翻了
那只是問題是
如果我們今天在講一些比較微觀的東西
一些特殊的標的
那他可能有一些議題要產生的
或是有一些新的力度要發展
那這些東西
如果說你沒有一些專有的資訊源的話
基本上它比較難為你帶的優勢
當你有這樣的一些資訊之後
其實你也不太需要去跟別人做討論
以前你會需要跟別人做討論
可能大家一起去看一份財報
可以得出不一樣的結論
或者大家一起去看一份資料
跟一個PQ的計算
或者試占率的計算
當每個人的input都丟進來
你會產生一些新的想法
但現在不用
現在基本上AI就可以直接
幫你把所有的scenario丟出來
所以我覺得AI對我們工作
最大的一個影響是
你發現你不太需要去跟人對話了
你只要多跟機器講話就好
當然這可能有階段的問題
就是到我下這個階段
就是我基本上可以取得很多的資訊的時候
我是發現我不需要去跟人對話
但是如果我之前
就是一樣可以取得很多資訊沒有AI的話
我要去完成類似的工作
其實我是需要去跟很多人對話的
所以我覺得AI它某種程度上
算是一個哀人的福音
就是你可以降低很多跟人接觸的一個機會
再來就是在資訊的獲得上面
其實社群媒體跟AI
我覺得它算是相輔相成
而且是並進的
就是以X來講
我覺得X現在就是一個非常好
去獲得各種消息或是資訊的一個平台
它甚至是比所有的AI本身來得好
就是你不會想要去請AI幫你講說
這個禮拜或說這幾天發生什麼事情
然後接著一個一個去看
它其實相對沒有效率的
你只要把X打開來
或是把一些社群
像蠻多人喜歡看Frez
所以我覺得Frez
其實也不能這樣說
就是說當然世界上本來
就是有很多的怪咖跟笨蛋
只是在Frez上面的怪咖跟笨蛋特別多
所以看Frez是一個
我覺得對心理負擔很大的平台
但現在我去看FB覺得是OK
以前看FB覺得FB都是老人家的根據地
但現在可能自己也變成是相對老人的思維
所以FB的各種價值觀跟我是比較合的
X上面可以獲得很多最新的資訊
所以如果說你把FB上面的feed
就是把它調整成是非常客製化的一個情形
要不然說你該追的東西
追不該追的東西去刪掉
你在這邊去做一個資訊
如果你要用你的filter
跟X上面去追踪一些特別有幫助的人
或是消息的來源的話
其實在資料的獲取方面
用社群的效益是大於用AI
我覺得
而且AI它會幫你白燒很多token
所以一般像是現在一些事件的發展
就還是跟過往一樣
去逛社群
然後像是金石
它會有一些隨時的推播
當然有些可能是假的
你還要去filter一下
但大多數來講
獲得很多很新很快的
現在正在世界上發生的一些事件的消息
對於一些想要去Trade消息的人來說
或是有時候要去找靈感的話
其實這都還是一個非常好的做法
再來就是在公司的
比較基本面的一個研究的話
其實AI是現在幫助我最大的
AI在看財報實在是有夠厲害的
我們講的AI
像我自己目前都是使用Proplexity Computer
裡面我最常使用的模型是Fable file
之前有一段時間會回去用GPT
可是我還是覺得GPT有一種油臭味
他的回答一看就是GPT的回答
Fable的話其實是還蠻不錯
但是他也有一定程度的風險
或說要注意的東西就是
他認為他自己永遠都是對的
所以其實跟Dario的個性是有點像
如果你今天真的讓Amphlopic
去掌握世界大權的話
我覺得會出事情
因為他們真的是認為
AI是要掌握在少數人的口袋裡面
但除了那些莫名的自滿之外
其實在分析上面
如果說給予適當的引導的話
在Propexy Computer搭配AI模型
或者說即便你用它的Orchestra
就是直接讓它去支用裡面的各種模型
它會幫你盡量的去省一些Token
我覺得還是OK
就是去看財務數字這方面
其實基本上下都是直接交給AI做的
我相信未來只會更嚴重
就是以後可能在財報裡面去找一些線索
或是漏洞或是問題的話
都會盡可能的直接丟給AI了
像以前的做法是自己會去翻一翻
可是問題是其實各行如各山
像我們自己的做法還是以題材股為主
所以其實我會去接觸很多
我不一定熟悉的產業
當然這個在投資的1.0.1裡面
它不一定是一個好事情
大家都告訴你一定要投資
你看得懂的東西
但整個說這是我們的風格
就是我們本來就會去做一些題材股
所以本來就是在財報裡面
有時候一些美美絞絞
你不一定會看得懂
好像一些合約資產合約負債
雖然直接講這個名字
大家腦中一定會產生某一些印象
可是在一些行業它不一定會這樣子或是說收貨跟交款的時間這個可能在一些行業裡面你一定會力求說你要趕快交款什麼的如果說交款時間拉長可能會遇到一些違約的問題
或是人家會倒債之類的
但在一些產業
他可能不一定有這樣子的問題
因為他客戶結構
或者說他客戶的屬性的特徵
所以導致你知道他被違約機率是很低的
以前你要自己去翻
去找線索去對我什麼的
但是我覺得有AI之後
這個都超簡單的
你只要告訴他一些框架
或甚至你不用告訴他框架
他就可以知道說這個產業該怎麼樣去讀財報
重點是你只要確保你的模型夠強就好
只要有在付錢
就覺得不會有太大的問題
所以其實我覺得有了AI之後
就是自己花時間去閱讀財報的時間是變短的
然後再來就是
像是年報裡面去抓一些關鍵數字
基本上下也都是讓AI去跑
當然有一些那種定型化的東西
你還是會直接用Ctrl加F是比較快的
因為最終在AI的使用上
除非說你是預算無上限
雖然我們其實對預算已經非常的寬鬆了
只是有時候還是一個效率的問題
像有一些數字我知道說在年報裡面
我Ctrl加F關鍵字去找就可以立刻找到
我就自己去找就好了
如果叫AI去看
他看回來
那他可能就再搞個三五分鐘
他要重新跟你確認一些你的需求
那一來一往除了花錢之外也花掉更多時間
所以其實我覺得就是因為AI已經用了一兩年以上了
那自己會開始產生一些想法
就是我們不是那種盲信AI者
我還是會跟大家講說
就是你在一些新銳跟新穎的資訊獲取上
其實你會使用大量的社群媒體
社群媒體背後也是有很多AI driven的東西
包含說像是那些Algorithm的優化
那都跟AI有非常大的關係
但其實你用那些工具就好了
所以我不認為說
AI會取代世間的所有東西的核心在這邊
因為你還是會發現說
有些東西你自己下去做
它其實在實務上還是會比較快
有些東西你熟悉的
格式是差不多的
其實我自己去用Ctrl F去搜尋
一定是比AI去帕國爬都來得快
所以只是說以一個大方向的研究來講
我今天切入一個新的產業
或者說既有的產業
我已經知道框架是怎麼樣
我確實是直接把他的財報跟年報丟給AI
然後接著去裡面老鼠隻
就可以很快的獲得答案
現在重點來了
就是我們不會有事沒事
除非說今天是有靈感
人家告訴我某一間公司
我特別要去做研究
不然其實像我自己的工作流
他也是有比較偏向說
基本上我們去市場裡面
去找正在發生的故事
正在發生故事很簡單
就是市場裡面什麼東西正在漲
或說有什麼族群正在跑
這個你也可以去問AI
但是我還是不相信AI
我還是會選擇用自己的眼睛去看
我覺得這可能就是去鑑別一些績效的最主要的來源之一雖然我這樣講也有可能是我還有一些盲點說不定用AI做可以更有效率但是我至今我是發現說這段自己看還是最好
就是你自己在盤中看感覺
你看到一些東西
特別強勢一些族群走出來
或是一些事件的驅動
可能像前陣子跟大家講說
這個揮答的Power的白皮書
雖然最後面看起來
Power的白皮書
它沒有帶起全面的族群
但是有少部分的股票
確實被它帶起來了
那抑或是
最近就在講說記憶體12嗨變8嗨
甚至有些人講說會變4嗨之類的
如果你靠自己
平常對於股票跟產業的敏感度的話
它所篩出來的線索
會比我今天問AI來的更有效
因為我試著去問AI過
但是我發現說
AI在這方面達的不夠好
可能是因為它沒有賠過錢
它沒有在市場裡面
血淋淋的被虐殺或者說被搞過
所以在這方面敏感度
可能目前還不夠
我相信如果真的很認真去券它是有機會
但一樣這個是類似那種CP值的問題
就是說你有必要去取代社群媒體
幫你看資訊的能力嗎
沒有必要因為你可能要花很多錢
所以差不多這樣一個感受
就是在盤中自己找到一些東西之後
今天這個東西我想要快速的去理解它
我可能就會先請AI告訴我
這個產業的overview是長什麼樣子
然後接著可能會去
請AI去挖我的Google Drive
我有特別開一個Google Drive
然後把一些報告跟一些memo丟到裡面
請他去撈
就例如說今天是跟Power
或是跟某個光通某個Xava元件有關的東西
請你去幫我找關於這個東西的討論
接著我就開始非常密集的跟AI對話
然後去把我要的東西全部都問出來之後
我就去自信下單
所以有時候很有趣的是
當然我們有些東西會是偏向深思熟慮
就是我研究了半天之後
然後再決定要去買進
然後接著到市場上去慢慢收這個東西
但是我自己注意到
我現在可能有高達3到5成左右的買賣
其實它還是比較偏向是某種
improvise的行為
就是我在盤中我看到了一個東西
我立刻的去查資料
然後跟WanAI在外加
有時候去看一下社群
有沒有人在討論這個東西
去確保我現在所獲得的資訊
跟我了解的深度
以及我所估出來的一個數字
是優於社群
或是優於分析師們的估計
然後接著
我就會去買進它
所以其實有蠻多東西是在盤中發生的
以前在盤中可能會花很多時間去看新聞就是什麼XQ或這些看盤問題都會跳一些新聞然後一些什麼字節什麼盤中會看這個其實現在就比較少會看這個現在就是單純的用量價
去找到一些東西之後
然後接著快速的去研究它
絕大多數的東西
其實你都已經有一些概論了
因為其實股票就是輪來輪去這幾個族群
然後接著去找到一些
你可能發現這個東西
它的擁擠度是不高的
然後跟你獲得的資訊
跟你所了解到的東西
是市場可能還有落差的
搭配他現在有突破就去買
所以其實你要說哪個東西比較重要
到底是我們去識別這個東西
然後接著確保他型態是走我們要的型態
然後接著再把籌碼打進去
這個比較重要
還是說是AI幫我做研究這一段
我反而覺得
一開始會對AI做研究這段
頗刮目相看
覺得說太厲害了
我現在什麼生產力超強
但我後來發現
因為身邊會做這件事情的人不少
就是大家都會做這件事情
所以這件事情
它某個程度上只是有點像是
我們現在好像每個人都帶一個Jarvis
帶著一個管家
每個人都有
沒有Jarvis的人可能連考場都進不去
大家都有管家
這個管家知道說
少爺你今天要來考試
我幫你把你的2B鉛筆磨好
叉子弄好
以下是你的小本本
就是你以前考鉛不是會去賣那種
可能一本50塊100塊
然後讓你數記一些東西嗎
公式什麼的
他把這個小本本告訴你
然後說好你現在可以上戰場了
可是重點就是上戰場去做的各種判斷
其實都還是要回歸到自己
靠自己的一些那種敏感度跟感受去做
所以其實到近期我越來越想去研究
就是過往一些量化的朋友所做的事情
因為我在想說
會不會我們這種感覺的東西
為我們所帶來的一個績效
都是一個短暫的東西
因為畢竟雖然可能在過去的十幾年
都是還蠻不錯
但是你不知道未來十二十年是怎麼樣
你也不知道說會不會其實過去的十幾年
就是你人生的高光時刻之類的
所以或許還是得把一些感覺的東西
因為現在很相信感覺
你要把這個感覺東西要有辦法量化出來
然後變成是一個可以重複去實踐的東西
有可能是在下個階段我想要去努力的一個方向
但以目前這個階段來講
我覺得非常踏實的一點是
就是我們會用人去看一些信號
然後用人的下單你的資金去判斷說
你買一個東西有沒有人要去跟
有沒有市場資金跟著推
賣壓大不大
我這個都還是非常人為的去做判斷
但是後端的一些處理
就是以前我可能後端的處理是
我處理的零零閃閃
像Stanley Drucker-Miller講的
反正先買再研究
我先買盤中或盤後
我再去慢慢看
現在盤中跟盤後慢慢看
它可以變成是
在10分鐘 20分鐘內就可以完成的東西
可是你說它是不是
這個交易裡最關鍵的東西
好像不一定是
所以目前在自己的工作上
就會呈現的是一種
我覺得非常hybrid的一個模式
在短期內還沒有辦法看到
會往人的方向去傾斜
或是往更多AI去傾斜
反而是在找一個折衷的平衡
怎麼樣讓人跟AI結合得更好
我覺得這是後面努力的方向
所以如果我今天可以開一個spec出來
怎麼樣讓我的工作效率再變得更高
然後怎麼樣我可以去有感的感受到
我的生活變得更輕鬆的話
特別是我現在剛好在日本
其實我就覺得像一些菜單要翻譯
我現在還是會打開手機
然後可能用Google Translate
它有影片即時翻譯
就是你只要攝影機對著它就會去翻譯
然後抑或是你拍張照他就會幫你翻譯
可是這個都還是會延遲都還是會有時間
如果說有照理他真的可以像
就像Siri他曾經給大家一個夢境
就是說他那個螢幕他是有一個感知功能的
他可以直接看著這個螢幕上的東西
立刻就跟你做互動
類似像大家講說AirPods要出一個有攝影機的
其實我是非常期待低延遲的AI
可以加入到我們的生活裡面
不然說剛剛前面講的一些工作應用
其實我覺得效益都會再拉到更高
可是當然這些東西都沒有辦法
立刻的去給你一個保證
就是你因為這樣可以帶來多少的績效
但是它幫你心理的踏實感
是真的健顧的蠻穩的
所以有時候我甚至覺得
這有點possible effect
有點像是安慰劑效應的感覺
你過往下單的時候可能不太穩
因為你是先擺在研究之類
但是現在你下單的時候
其實你都是非常有自信的
但是這不影響
就是可能以最近那種震盪的盤勢
你可能不小心下來之後被幹到停損
或者說回去想想越想越不對勁
還是會去做一些檢查
這都還是會發生
所以我覺得市場這個地方有趣的是
因為競爭者重
各行各業的人都在
然後再來就是會用AI的人也是一大堆
所以你無法感受到
AI為你帶來一種那種壓倒性的優勢
但是它可以讓你整個心態變穩
有點像那種玄學面
讓你心態變穩
讓你在做決定的時候
更有莫名的自信產生
這個是確實會發生的事情
所以其實講到後來
我自己都會覺得說好像有點心虛
這到底AI幫了我什麼東西沒錯他真的是幫我變成一個更強大的人可是因為就是在市場這種充滿不確定性跟各種隨機事件都可能會發生的地方你說就算你有一個超級AI幫你分析了
什麼有的沒有的東西
你對一個產業跟買點都是研究到非常的透徹
因為這樣子你選擇要開一個大槓
你最近也看到situation awareness
他非常的了解
你說在AI的領域有多少人可以比他理解
很少但那個槓開到這麼大就還是會爆炸
你說那我槓不要開這麼大就好了
對那你不要開這麼大的話
那你可能最終你拉長開
你也是跟某種那種半導地指數
說不定也是差不多啦
或是說贏人家一點點而已
那可是你可能在AI這邊
是要投入那種指數等級的開銷
所以最後算起來也不一定會是划算的
所以這是近期在AI使用上一些感受
雖然把自己的工作的流程跟大家分享
雖然聽起來是有點玄幻
但是我覺得如果你自己有下去做的
應該可以懂我在講什麼
反正就是你盤中視頻到訊號
然後現在後端的處理
有一個AI可以幫你去做
那最終你都還是那個開槍的人
只是開箱下去到底會不會打中獵物
會不會有好的結果
其實跟後段的AI
我覺得一開始你也以為關係很大
但最終發現說
因為會使用這個工具人太多了
所以甚至你現在會有感的感受到
市場好像有一點變得更有效率了
就是有一些東西
即便它目前只是在過往來說
它這個地方不應該長這麼多
但它現在就先狂噴了
所以你就算有一些資訊的優勢
你可能會聰明反而被聰明
你反而會在後面的一些回檔裡面受一些傷害
因為要可能就一次反應完了
所以市場的節奏也變得非常快
我覺得就是因為說市場有一些新的變化
所以導致你很難去量化
到底你的工作跟AI所帶來的output
有什麼超級大的一個直接的關係
我覺得是很難去講出來的
所以大概這邊稍微跟大家分享一下
自己的一些心得
好那接下來我們來進入QA的部分
第一位Max
夢工猛男你好
你說買體驗比買東西重要的概念
讓我購物引好了很多
那也希望9月可以動起來找工作
另外可以跟8月24號生日我說那四個字嗎
生日快樂也祝夢宮跟廣大的聽眾
身體健康績效衝破外太空
我前幾天看到新聞還是什麼
有講到說韓國有一個購物網站
嚴格上來說它不是購物網站
它是一種去滿足你多巴胺的網站
就是你可以把一堆東西放進去購物車
你可以挑選然後接著還可以選擇運送
但這東西一輩子都不會來
這樣獲得蠻多人的喜好
所以這或許也是一個解方吧
下面一位皮卡乒乓乓乓乓乓乓乓乓
下面一位
Nester悟安
孟公大你好
9月7号是我女友生日希望孟公去嘎可以开金口用客家话跟大家说那四个字阿美個字祝美食獵人尼亞生日快樂願你能夠保有最純粹的心
你永遠是最棒的
那另外如果留言成功
希望把圖示換成生日蛋糕的圖樣
也衷心感謝您的節目能夠在這個動盪的世界
給予我們一處放鬆療癒的空間
也祝奇卡一家和聽眾們都能夠平安順利
健康績效非高高
那我們祝美食獵人尼亞生日快樂
也希望你們兩個百年好和
下面一位竹北庫里
孟公赤嘎你好
我是小小地方泌尿科医师
十分感谢孟公赤嘎
陪伴了我各种通勤上班的时间
最近有件工作上的困扰
想要请教孟公赤嘎
我目前在地区医院上班
稳定稳定
但是觉得自己年余40
体力不太能够附和值班
挂号熬夜要花好几天补眠
Uncode值班时
或是病人状况不稳时
心理的压力有点大
有点影响到生活
现在有个机会
可以在附近的诊所工作
收入理论上差不多可能甚至还多一点
可以少去值班的压力
但是夜整的时间比较多
一周两次到三次到九点半
小孩准备要上小学了
觉得去诊所可能会少一些陪伴小孩
平日晚上或是陪他们念书聊天的时间
感觉各有好坏
但还是想偷偷请教梦工去搞的想法
谢谢
那祝梦工一家人身体健康和家快乐
红颜路比长红
另外肖南资本有没有机会投资开发手游
出去外面以及客厅雇小孩
不能夠使用電腦
首先非常感謝這位兄弟的祝福
向南資本的話
目前我們是有手遊的規劃
也有自己開發遊戲的規劃
所以除了去投別人的遊戲
想都沒有想到
就是我們自己也會成為開發商的一員
所以希望後面可以端出一些有趣的東西
讓大家玩
然後再來講說小小的困擾
不知道什麼
我直覺應該是要選附近的診所
因為一個是你要on call
要值班
然後接著病人的造成心理壓力什麼的
那個確實是對於一個怎麼說
我雖然不是醫師
但是我光是去訓練你這樣講怪怪
就是說我把自己置入在你的身體裡還是很怪
反正就是我將心比心
我將心比心我可以了解就是在那種比較大醫院裡面
確實醫生可能壓力是比較大
我們身邊或是說像我自己的鄰居
我家裡的親戚有一些醫師
我感受是這樣子
就是大多數人可能還是覺得
在診所的生活會比較好一點
當然這可能有一點以偏概全或什麼
但至少我在身邊感受到的體驗是這樣子雖然說可能會有一些夜診的時間一週兩次到三次可是我覺得還OK因為你的時間可能整個變彈性然後在加熱陪伴小孩的時候
可能也不用擔心說
隨時接到電話要幹嘛
所以雖然有一些固定的時間
感覺是被拿走了
但是你換來的是其他時間的一種清閒感
我覺得清閒感是非常重要的
這也是我一生在修煉的課題之一
就是我每次出來玩的時候
我就是很怎麼說
有時候會覺得遺憾
有時候也會覺得蠻討厭自己
就是為什麼我會一直想要去做自己工作相關的東西
但最後面A君跟我講的東西我是有釋懷
他說其實你是喜歡的
就你嘴巴在那邊抱怨
但你是喜歡的
如果今天不讓你去做這些事情
你可能也會覺得很憂鬱
你去做人你可能也會很憂鬱
因為就覺得說好像你沒有花太多時間陪孩子
或是為什麼你要把自己搞的壓力這麼大
所以可能就是去抓中間的一種平衡
所以我自己會認為直覺來看
可能去診所會相對好一點
但我不想去干預人家一生的選擇
只能夠說如果是我
我把自己放在你的鞋子裡的話
我去想我會覺得是這樣子
下面有一位
只書邊邊一點
夢公夢公我老婆9月6號生日
請你幫忙說生日快樂
謝謝生日快樂
夢公是我老婆少數認可的男人
挂號編佑席是第一名
編佑席是誰啊
謝謝夢公常分享直男的想法
讓我老婆比較可以理解男生
減少認知上摩擦的衝突
祝夢公去給他一家平安快樂
聽眾大家一起爆轉
確實希望大家一起爆轉
然後再來講說直男的想法
自從你們一直在講說什麼
什麼直男巧胡
然後很直男之後
我老婆也在社群上看到這些東西
然後她非常的不以為然
她就說你就是一個臭直男
所以並不是說我真的在什麼兩性關係
或是跟老婆跟家人的相處上特別有一套
我只是比較敢而已
就是我知道蠻多人他會演他會裝
然後可能從婚前一路裝裝到婚後
然後最後面受不了終於爆炸
我就從以前到現在都不裝
而且我甚至是還蠻驕傲
我不裝這件事情
並不是說什麼我是白爛
我還是會去改變還是會進步還是會去妥協
只是盡量不去演
最後面發現說其實兩性關係
其實我覺得不管男生或是女生都一樣
可是你發現說你給人家他們俄國的諺語
你給他你的手掌
最後面你整隻手都被吃下去
就軟土生絕
所以有些底線應該要踩住
然後有些想法就算可能看起來是比較不正確一點
但是他就是你的想法
每個想法都是值得被聽到的
然後再加上現在的世界上
可能有蠻多那種驼獸或者說工具人
然後他們會讓一些女生
可能會有一些錯誤的期待
會覺得說男生好像每個都應該是這樣
像一條狗之類
可是實際上就不是這樣子
反過來說女生也是有一些在雷的
然後讓其他女生感覺是被
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕